Senator Rand Paul becomes the first
Republican to come out against a ban of
tick tocks he says he will defend the
app but my next guest says Innovation is
National Defense joining me now pop
Investments investor Anthony pompliano
uh pop you know I saw your comment on
Tick Tock being weaponized against the
United States and to and of course to
think of the ban as as in that point The
Innovation is a national as National
Defense I I guess it's not unusual for
Rand Paul to take that position but I
think most people at least most folks
who understand what's at stake probably
believe a ban is what's what we should
be doing right
well look I think you got to separate
out both the band and then this idea of
innovation as a National Defense right
uh everyone's focused on the current
moment and we should be and we should
address it it's very obvious that we
basically have two concerns one the
dumbing down of an entire generation of
children but also a lot of data and
privacy issues that we got to get to uh
the bottom of but I'm more concerned
about how do we prevent this in the
future and I think that's where
Innovation comes in you know in this
country we have this idea that uh things
just get better but I actually think
that this is a wake-up call to the tech
industry to the education industry and
to the American government right we need
to better train educate our people we
need to encourage entrepreneurship and
we need to compete in a free market and
the next great social app that gets
created we should hope that Americans do
it that's based here in the U.S and
it'll negate these types of issues
moving forward but Innovation is
absolutely critical to the National
Defense of this country but it's also
critical to the economic prosperity of
this country and I think the more that
we can focus on competing stop
complaining and compete get our people
building the best products the best
technology stuff stop trying to slow
down Innovation encourage it and I think
we'll be in a better position yeah I'm
with you one million one million percent
uh ironically you know we might have
lost sight of creative destruction I
want to uh also take it out to bitcoin
because it's above 28
000 really really building a nice set of
steam here in a more perfect world how
could Bitcoin have played a role in
helping to avoid or mitigate the current
banking crisis
yeah look I think understanding what's
going on in the banking world is
important uh the fractional Reserve
System obviously induces risk
um and people need to be aware of the
risk that they're taking now FDIC
insurance and many other things have
been put in place helped to mitigate
that I don't think we want to live in a
world where individuals or small
businesses are having to underwrite the
solvency of the banks that they're
putting their deposits in
um and so I think fractional Reserve is
what it is we have systems in place to
mitigate it but what we just saw was
there are millions if not tens or
hundreds of millions of people who just
woke up to how fractional Reserve
banking works yeah Bitcoin was in the
you know ashes of the last great
financial crisis I believe we're in a
financial crisis right now uh and
Bitcoin ends up not only being a
solution to that problem but I think
Bitcoin also represents this idea of
actually lowering risk which is very
important every single asset in the
world induces risk and so when you look
at something like treasuries I mean
these Banks were buying things that were
supposed to be some of the safest Assets
in the world when you buy a home there's
risk that's why you buy insurance when
you cross the street there's risk but an
asset like Bitcoin that is programmatic
not controlled by anyone and continues
to build out the most decentralized
Computing Network in the world that
actually in my mind reduces risk and so
if somebody is trying to be conservative
and they want to store their wealth for
the next 20 50 100 years there's very
few Assets in the world that I have more
confidence in than Bitcoin and so I
think that people should just take the
time to learn about it you know it's
really amazing too to your point at this
moment in time over the last few months
the last few weeks uh you know Bitcoin I
think to your to your point is making
that case more than ever uh you all
posted a Bloomberg cover I thought it
was pretty intriguing right Powell
trying to beat inflation on one hand to
save the banks at the same time listen I
think he's made a mess of things but the
Federal Reserve I mean where do you see
its role it just to me it's just too
powerful Pomp and and I think this is
going to keep making things worse
yeah look I tend to be someone who
thinks that market intervention actually
makes things more complex uh it ends up
throwing off the free market and so uh
ultimately I decide that the free market
is probably the better referee now with
that said we have to be realistic we
live in a system where there is a
central bank uh the Federal Reserve does
have a lot of influence uh especially
when they intervene and I think we have
to also be honest with ourselves I don't
want that job right I don't envy the
position that they're in because it is
nearly an impossible situation you have
to intervene if you are a politician or
a central Banker you're going to
mitigate short-term risk whether that's
the right decision or not over the long
term you're going to mitigate that
short-term risk which they did in 2020
and so naturally those Market
interventions throw off the free market
they end up complicating stuff and now
what we have is a situation where I do
think that cover is correct save the
banks or save the dollar and so if we
have six percent inflation a very key
metric that people kind of have
forgotten we through quantitative
tightening took almost a trillion
dollars off the central bank's balance
right we eased interest rates to five
percent inflation is still at six
percent in the official reading so we
threw everything we had at it we never
got inflation below six percent and now
we're expanding the balance sheet again
likely going to drop interest rates over
the next year or so I don't see
inflation necessarily having an easy
ride back to two percent yeah so it just
being what it is they're probably gonna
I merely I don't know why they are so
stuck on two percent I think they should
make it three percent and to your point
they put so much money in the system you
can't take it out overnight no matter
what you do take it slow Road maybe we
would have less of these wild gyrations
hey it's so good to have you on pump
Anthony thank you so much